- Hi, I'm Aria and I'm in Los Angeles.
- Hi, I'm Aishwarya and I live in Mumbai.
- My name's Luisa and I'm
live in Sao Paolo, Brazil.
- My name is Red, I live in Tokyo.
- Hi, I'm Saba and I live in Berlin.
- I'm Giovanni and I'm from Mexico City.
- I wanted to see what trash
looked like around the world.
So I contacted six BuzzFeeders,
at offices around the globe
to go about their week,
and throw away things
as they normally would,
and at the end of the week
to empty out their trash,
and just to sort it
and see what sort of
trash they're producing,
and how they could potentially
reduce their waste.
- [Man] Whoa.
- [Aishwarya] Let's put all
the plastic on one side.
- Plastic.
Plastic.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Aria] So that's more plastic here.
- Plastic, it just really
stinks a lot right now.
- Make it stop, make it stop.
Why is there so much trash?
(speaking in foreign language)
I don't do any sorting stuff.
- Here in Mexico, we don't
separate trash that often.
Finally I take my trash
out, and it was weird for me
because it was like a weird week;
because I invited some
friends and we have beers,
I eat a lot of chips, and I
realized I make a lot of trash.
- I guess we don't really
realize how much trash
we do tend to gather and build
over the course of a week.
And this was a week that I
would consider a light week,
in terms of me being at home.
I didn't do very much at home.
For a light week, I'd say
that's a fairly sizeable chunk.
- Now honestly I'm very
surprised at all the plastic
that I've collected, because
at home I'm not into packaged.
Like I'm into a healthy lifestyle,
so at home I wouldn't collect a lot of,
packaged foods, and stuff
like that but I guess,
I'm not as sustainable as I though I was.
- There is lots of cat food wrappers and
ice cream wrappers too because
it was very hot these past days.
Juice cartons.
Also this packaging for
vegetables and salads, and grapes.
I don't know if it's a lot.
Some of it is probably not necessary.
This is the waste that I've
produced during the week.
In total, I think it is a lot.
And I think it wouldn't
be such a big problem
if we knew that all the recyclable parts
would be actually recycled.
(gentle music)
- I guess I could
definitely work on myself.
Less takeout, more cooking, but if I cook,
then I should also pay attention to how
the vegetables and the
salad and everything else,
all the ingredients are wrapped.
You can do better, Saba,
is my conclusion to this.
(speaking in foreign language)
- Even if you don't
produce a lot of trash,
you can always reduce it.
- When I buy a product,
I never think about
the material it's made of.
I mostly just think about my convenience.
And I feel like now, I'm gonna
be more aware and mindful
about the kind of trash I'm making.
I think everyone should just
life one step at a time,
and if everyone does
it, then it's definitely
gonna be a great, great future ahead.
- Hey, Unsolved is on a new
channel, and now your part.
- [Both men] Subscribe here.
- That was my part.